sprigs of orchids and garlands of
marigolds waiting for buyers in
bangkok's bustling Flower Market
floral arrangements usually used for
blessings placed on altars and shrines
for good luck
Traders know it's going to be a busy
weekend
I think people are looking forward to
working and choosing someone who's more
capable for prime minister I think there
won't be any hiccups on the election day
I think that people have been ready for
this for a long time but good luck
garlands may not be enough the United
Thai nation party led by prime minister
prayer tenocha could be punished by
voters for his response to the covid-19
pandemic
the party that's consistently led the
polls is per tie with a progressive
economic platform
their candidate for PM is the daughter
of tax in shinawat the self-exiled
former prime minister who's known to be
Keen to return home
the deciding factor might be moved
forward a new party that's promised a
wide-ranging reforms including
controversially to laws concerning the
monarchy
their appeal appears to have extended
beyond the youth vote despite the large
number of parties contesting this
election there's going to be a
relatively Simple Choice for Thai voters
on Sunday so they want the next
occupants of government house to be
parties supported by the military who
will maintain the status quo
or do they want to change
the influence of the military is never
far away in Thai politics but most
assume a coup is unlikely at least in
the short term there are powers that be
behind the scene trying to shape
outcomes beyond the rules and the um the
Constitutional provisions
but the landslide will be hard to
overturn if the numbers are so clear the
margins of Victory are so unassailable
for putai and maybe followed by move
forward then it'll be difficult
to shave the margins with these
disqualifications and distortions the
official result may not be declared for
at least a month and many expect
complications after the vote
but if the voters turn out in large
numbers their choices will be hard to
ignore Tony Chang Al Jazeera Bangkok